مشروع قد يغير شكل الشرق الاوسط الممر
الاقتصادي بين الهند واوروبا اتفاقيه
اعلنت على هامش قمه مجموعه العشرين بين
سبع دول وكيانات وحظيت باهتمام عالمي رغم
غموض تفاصيلها
[موسيقى]
في ثلاث قارات ينطلق من الهند بحرا باتجاه
موانئ الامارات ثم المتابعه برا في
السعوديه والاردن واسرائيل وصولا الى
اليونان ثم دولي غرب اوروبا يهدف الى
الرفع حجم تبادل التجاري وزياده مرور
البضائع وتعزيز سلاسل الامداد الاقليميه
وتقليل الانبعاثات المضره بالبيئه
يبحث تصدير الكهرباء والهيدروجين النظيف
عبر انابيب ورغم ان الولايات المتحده طرف
رئيس في الاتفاقيه فان دورها الرعايه
والاستثمار ولا يشملها الممر
الولايات المتحده لم تحدد جدولا زمنيا
لانطلاق المشروع لكن مصادر رسميه رجحت
اعداد خطه خلال 60 يوما لوضع محددات
المشروع على ان يستكمل العام المقبل وما
تزال التكاليف المتوقعه للمشروع غير واضحه
المشروع الجديد يستهدف الحج من النفوذ
الصيني في العالم من خلال مبادره الحزام
والطريق الضخمه التي تشمل اكثر من 150
دوله من عده قارات ويثير الممر الجديد
تساؤلات عن تاثيره على طرق التجاره
الحاليه خبراء حذروا من تراجع اهميه قناه
السويس التي تستحوذ على 12% من التجاره
العالميه لكن اكاديميين مصريين يقولون ان
الممر لا يلغي عمل القناه نظرا لعده عوامل
فنيه واقتصاديه وانت هل ترى ان المشروع
الجديد سيؤثر على ممرات مائيه ومنها قناه
السويس
[موسيقى]